hello belief nation I started the mentor
me series with the goal to try to hang
around people who've done a lot more
than us and by sticking with them a
little bit longer hopefully some of
their ideas their strategy their
mindsets that belief seeps into us to
help us become the best version of
ourselves so today we're going to learn
from Tony Robbins and examine some of
his best motivational clips that he
posted in 2016 as an incentive for you
to go for your best this year mentor me
Tony
clip number one that's my personal
favorite and as always guys as Tony's
talking if he says something that really
really really resonates with you please
leave in the comments below
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired as well enjoy
Oh
the number one thing that's going to
change your life the only thing that
will change your life change your
business change your money change your
relationship because you must raise your
standard I know that sounds boring
stupid basic but it's the truth the only
thing that changes our life long term is
when we raise our standards what does
that mean that sounds so boring and dumb
it means that all of us in life have
things we want we don't get what we want
we get what we have to have memorize it
earlier we all get what we tolerate in
ourselves and other people but when
you're no longer willing to tolerate
something that's when your life changes
the difference in people is their
standards period the difference in
people is their standards period and
what I mean by standards everyone in the
world has a list of things they think
they should do I should lose weight I
should work out I should spend more time
with my kids I should work harder I
should make more calls I should I should
I should I should and then you know what
people don't do their shirts and they
get mad at themselves and they when I
call [ __ ] all over themselves they beat
themself up about it
what changes people is when you should
becomes a must when suddenly the thing
you said should happen pass to happen
that's when human beings change it's
like if you want to take the island and
you're the head of the army you want to
take the our island the most powerful
way to take the island is burn the boats
because if there's no way to go back
it's amazing what happens when it's a
must to do something versus a [ __ ]
that's what makes you them being succeed
there is another level the only reason
you keep seeing there isn't as you feel
so exhausted about where you are but
life the universe or God is just testing
you because there is another level if
this is good
giant jump to excellence Giants start
good pour to good to excellence there's
a level where all your dreams are
realized there's a level that you've
always dreamed that it is real it has
not gone away but it takes that extra
burst when you think there's nothing
left there's no way you've tried
everything ten million times and you
keep going it's almost like God is
saying if you keep hitting this wall
enough times I will see that you will
not stop that you were filled with that
level of determination faith and courage
and then the door opens and you get to
that next level but most people don't
know is the next level is just two
millimeters above and it's called
outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding what's it called what's it
called what's it called outstanding
magnificent unstoppable extraordinary
not excellent it's a different level
it's a level where you are not one of
the best you are the best you know
what's amazing you only have to be two
millions more than everybody else and
you get everything you get the joy the
last year the fun of the family the
passion the economics the freedom the
spirit it's all there
what Jerry Maguire called the Quan baby
all of it and it's just two million
years above and most excellent people
give up because they're exhausted and
there's some people go the harder I hit
it the more I hit it sooner or later
it's going down I'm not stopping and
when you do that enough it pops open
what makes you a leader is your ability
to make a decision who's with me on this
right and anybody can make the easy
decision right so what makes you a
leader is you can make the tough
decisions and what makes you a leader is
you make the decision what makes you
great leaders you know I may be wrong
but if I have to wait till everything's
resolved nothing's going to get resolved
so I'm going to get decision if I make a
decision and it's wrong I'll find out
quicker than if I sit on the fence while
my life goes by I remember I showed this
with maybe a few of you before but years
and years ago when we had the big Gulf
War generals you know Norman Schwarzkopf
friend of mine and passed away three
years ago
and I used to bring him in to talk about
leadership and one of the first times I
ever asked him I said
how do you define leadership you know
how do you know when a person is really
leader and he said well they can make
decisions he said I can remember when I
was he was an assistant to a to a
general and I forget what the exact
position is but he said he was
responsible for reading all the briefs
and this generals highest generals in
the army and it was a decision that need
to be made and had to deal with 10 years
of going back and forth with the
Pentagon trying to figure out if they're
gonna make a go one direction or another
was a gigantic decision that was gonna
affect the way the army was structured
how money was going to be divided what
resources are going to go where
and he said they brought in this group
of 20 people in and they had this
two-hour meeting and everybody got up
and pitched their side of what they
thought was right and at the end when it
was completely done the general said has
everyone said their piece he said yes he
said do this
it was plan a and Plan B whatever it was
out of the three choices they had and
everybody said okay usually okay
generals saluted and ran off to go
implement this thing and X Ward cop said
he was freaking out because he knew
there's no way that general could have
read everything even he'd read and this
was such a complex piece and there was
only two hours and everybody gave their
best but my god there's so many things
to consider and so he finally got up
enough courage he said to go the general
said generals listen
permission to speak freely he said he's
speak freely
he said general there's so much
information here and there's so much
here no one's been really going to know
for sure how the how could you just make
that decision like that
he said because someone had to make it
he said because it's been going around
for ten years back and forth and no one
being able to make a decision he said
what if you're wrong he said if I'm
wrong we'll find out quicker if I'm
right the job will be done next question
right it's like when you're put in
charge take command everyone in this
room knows how to create you're not a
manager of your life you're a creator of
your life or you wouldn't be in this
room how do you create your life you get
hungry for something don't you who has
done something your life that once
seemed difficult or impossible and now
it's part of your life who's got
something in your life this area say I
how did you do it you created it three
ways number one you decided there's
something you wanted so bad that you
unleashed all your desire you became
obsessed with it if it was a business or
a car or a relationship or a
transformation in your body if there's
something you once envisioned and now
it's real it's because you didn't just
envision it you brought so much emotion
to it then now it's in your life it was
once a dream it was once a goal and now
it's in your life
how many have something like that in
your life now say I you may take it for
granted now hopefully not but it was
once just a vision may have seemed
impossible at one time so how did you do
it
you started with a concrete vision of
what you wanted and you focused on it
continuously didn't you wherever focus
goes energy flows you envision something
you got clear about it and then you
started thinking about all the reasons
why you wanted it you got excited about
it so this is what's next for me now I
want this you may have dreamed about a
thought about and talked about it but
when you focus on something continuously
something magical happens you get
insights don't you you overhear a
conversation hear something you wouldn't
have heard if you didn't have that
outcome or goal that you wanted so badly
who's ever come up with something
obsessed about it didn't even know how
to do it and it just happened and it
came together who's that that experience
say I so why don't we happen to that
power now for your business in life
there was a day that I became wealthy
I'll tell you a day I know that day I
was rich I was broke I was pissed I was
angry at everybody else but who myself
but really underneath it was mad at
myself
I just couldn't beat myself up anymore
so I was pissed and I had a friend that
I loaned money to and I had barely
enough and I knew he needed it and I
gave him $1,200 and I'm here not able to
eat I'm down to like 25 26 dollars and
i'm sandi him calling him and he's not
returning my call and I just need some
money he's ignoring me I didn't mean
ordinance I'm pissed I'm frustrated
in midst of all this I'm also pragmatic
I got 25 and change called $26 what the
hell am I gonna do I don't have any
plans for economics
I got overhead that's crazy I'm living
this little tiny apartment for the
square feet and Miss California so I
thought okay when I was totally broke
earlier on when I'm 17 I used to save my
money up and go to the smorgasbord and
load up for a Christmas you know load up
for the week so I said I was in Venice
I'm gonna go over to Marina del Rey
where all the yachts are and there's
place there called El Torito and I'm
gonna go they have an all-you-can-eat
smorgasbord I'm gonna load up for the
winter I'm gonna get there so I didn't
drive there because I was gonna spend
the gas to get there plus I need the
walk so I walked there and I go in I'm
not dressed really great but swinging
away it's okay and I got a place right
by the window I can see these yachts
going by and I'm dreaming of what life
could be like and I'm starting to let go
of my anger and I'm starting to start
focus on what I want instead of what I
don't want
I'm gonna follow say I and that shifted
me just a bit and now I'm eating which
shifted me a lot and I got this giant
plate stacked up and I don't know what
the Mount was like whatever it was 695
795 right so I'm gonna do this I could
probably do this three or four times
right somewhere that range
cuz I'm finishing my meal this little
boy comes in dressed in a little suit I
honestly don't know how old he be
probably in the third grade so maybe
eight years old 9 years old something
like that and he was so adorable and he
opened the door for his mother as men he
was attractive lady and he came over he
pull out the seat for and she sat down
and I was she was a pretty lady but as
soon as she was I was totally obsessed
by this boy he was just he had presents
at 7 or 8 years old and it moved me I
don't know why I just it moved me and I
thought this kid is like pure he's I
wanted to always be this way he's such a
good kid he's a giver so I got up and I
paid for the meal and whatever was six
seven bucks so now I've got whatever
left 17 18 19 dollars and I walk up this
little boy I said excuse me
and I said I just want acknowledge you
for being such an extraordinary
gentleman
I said I saw the way you treated your
lady how you open the door how you
pulled the chair out
I said that's class I said my name's
Tony what's yours
they don't honestly members named
charlie or something and he looked up at
me and I said Charlie I said that's
amazing
taking your date up for a lunch like
this he goes well actually she's my mom
and I said that's even more cool and I
said he said oh but I I'm not taking a
lunch cuz I'm just I think he said it
was eight I said oh yes you are
I had no plan for this there's reach in
my pocket I took all the money I had
left seventeen eighty ninety dollars and
I put on the table
I said you're taking her to lunch he
looked up at me and he goes I can't take
that
I said sure you can he said why cuz I'm
bigger than you are
and he smiled real big and I didn't even
look at his mom I just turned and walked
away and I didn't walk out of that door
flew home I should have been freaking
out how am I gonna eat
but I didn't I flew because something
inside of me had finally got past
scarcity and finally realized there's
something inside of us more than our
limits specialist thing called money
that I had let terrorize me I got home
and the mailman came that day and I had
no idea I was gonna have my next meal
and if letter comes and it's from the
guy I loaned the money to handwritten
notes saying I've been avoiding you it's
wrong I'm so sorry you were there when I
needed you here's what I owe you plus a
little bit more and the 1200 was there
that's not a hundred for the time that I
had to take care of it
and for me thirteen or dollars that was
enough to like run my show for a month
or two and I cried and then I decided
what does this mean I thought this means
that whenever you give it's always going
to come back so you don't have to ever
think about that again just give
and the rewards be great and you can
ever imagine I don't know if that's
coincidence but I decided to believe
that day was the blessing when I became
rich and I can tell you honestly I've
had tough days in my life economically
emotionally like all of us but I've
never gone back to the scarcity I never
will the secret to living is giving do
it when you don't have it and I promise
you
scarcity will leave your life Steve's a
dear friend of mine and when he was
building the win I'll never forget he
was at my home in Sun Valley it just got
to meet him it was New Year's and
everybody else was standing watching the
fireworks and I was sitting at a table I
was basically doing brain no sucking out
of his brain everything I possibly could
how do you think about this what do you
how do you mark it and here's what I
learned from Steve people don't buy
products they buy feelings people don't
buy products they buy States people know
buy products they buy identities and he
and I went back and forth for about two
and half or 3 hours and became lifelong
friends the last decade and a half he
came to this seminar sat in the front
row and I'm not there's almost nothing
that makes me uncomfortable I'm like
what am I going to teach him but he sat
on this event at lunch took me to lunch
she goes this is the most valuable
session I've been in the last 10 years I
know I'm gonna do this was in 2008 he
said here's I'm going to do I'm going to
when all my competitors are shrinking
right now because they're trying to
survive I'm going to go build this giant
beach club that goes right to Las Vegas
Avenue I'm going to build this new
entrance I'm going to up my services he
said I'm going to do what you teach what
is the fundamental success to becoming
wealthy it's only one thing if you want
to be wealthy after you more for your
clients than who than anyone else you
have to add more what that is the entire
secret to wealth in business if you want
it in one sentence it's simple do more
for others than anyone else is doing add
more value and you will own them and
you'll own the market but he goes you
know I'm going to do Tony I'm gonna when
everybody else is shrinking I'm going to
add more value so all the high end
people are going to see how I'm doing
more and they're gonna come to me and
this down period is going to be the most
important period of my entire career
because when the condom
comes back and those guys start giving
services I already own these people
they're not going to leave me on their
home you got to ask yourself what do I
do to add more value and many of you
think adding more value means cutting
your prices or doing something that
nature sometimes adding value is raising
your price it's crazy
raising your price can increase your
sales if it's the right piece now if you
raise your price and do more no question
that could be the right thing in some
cases some of you your market is the
cheapest price maybe it's time to change
that business model because unless
you're wal-mart or Amazon or somebody
that can do things that massive volume
and lose money and sustain it you might
need a thing called a margin if you're
going to be successful in business you
want a high margin high margins come
from high human needs being that the
only way to deal with fear that I found
in my life is a couple ways one of those
ways is to turn it on itself and ask
yourself what am I afraid of I'm free of
that I got to be more afraid of what I'm
gonna miss out on missing out on my
mission missing out who I'm supposed to
be missing in other words if you're not
get get rid of fear than use fear use
fear or it uses you it's that simple so
you got to say okay what's the price if
I just stay doing this what's the price
what I need to really get scared if I
learn all this I don't follow through
that's something to be scared about
and then that fear will get you over
your fear it'll push you through turn
fear in itself second way you can do it
is use what you've probably heard me say
because I've used this in was 17 is my
little rocking-chair test right I'm
gonna I'm gonna sit myself in my rocking
chair I'm I'm 85 years old looking back
on my life and I say I didn't do this or
I did when I talk about the art of a
film when I explain to people always is
I didn't say science of fulfillment why
not because it's different for everyone
just like art what one person thinks is
beautiful somebody else might think is
ugly so if you want to know what's
beautiful as many people there are on
earth it's an art because everyone has a
different view if you want to know God
loves the universe loves go to the
forest and see it it's called massive
diversity it isn't a science it's an art
but that art
unmastered or create an ugly life an
ugly life and the phrase I use most
often I hope you've heard me saying you
take it in once again maybe deeper is
success without fulfillment is the
ultimate failure success without
fulfillment is the ultimate failure but
if we don't physically make a decision
how we're going to live then we'll show
up like everybody else because the human
mind is not going to make you happy this
brain of yours won't do it you have to
direct it and there's no worse fate than
to achieve everything and not be
fulfilled
how many have the days where you achieve
this huge goal and your brain always
wanted it and you got it and then your
brain went is this all there is who's
been there the worst experience it's
worse than failing isn't it because most
of you are achievers so failure never
stops you you just look at his little
bump on the road I'll try something what
but when you succeed and you fail when
you succeed and you're not fulfilled
that's scary if you find your passion
you're gonna have this tremendous energy
of sustainable energy but momentum
requires you always do the next thing
that keep the momentum going
and the reason you get yourself in a
passionate place is so that you change
your life and the only thing that
changes your life is making a decision
so while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions you
don't make decisions when you like I
don't know what do you think alright
let's decide if you make a decision in a
state without momentum if you make a
decision from a place where there's no
passion you are not going to get
momentum it'll kill momentum it's decide
commit and resolve some of you in the
past you've gotten momentum you've
gotten passionate you've even made a
decision but
a decision is the first step decision is
like a war I got to do this or that
alright I'm gonna make myself through
this but commitment is when you now
after you've decided you commit to do
this for the long term whether it's hard
or easy doesn't matter you're doing this
it takes it from this moment and it
carries you to the future even when
things are difficult and the third state
is resolved resolved means it's done
it's like it doesn't even if you took
action it's done inside you so it's done
out there there's no question whatsoever
then once you decide the only way the
commitment and the energy and the
momentum continues is if you take
immediate massive what my friends
massive life write down in your notes
massive action is the cure-all massive
action is the cure-all if you're having
a difficult time with something your
relationship isn't where you want it to
be your finances are not where you want
to be your body's not where you want to
be your business is not where it want to
be you need to take massive action and
if that doesn't work try something else
so that's his work try something else
keep going with massive action and you
will find the way because it will give
you momentum just the belief I like you
to try on I don't need an excuse to feel
good what if I don't need an excuse to
feel good I just feel good for no good
reason I'm I like this idea say I now
notice notice when I first said it you
guys are kind of quiet processing it
like I don't need to be a reason to feel
good oh how do I know to feel good most
people don't need a reason to feel bad
how's it going feel like crap how come
woke up
in a moment I like you to celebrate for
no good reason just because you decided
to but I mean really celebrates you can
rise up are you ready
well clap when I yell free we go crazy
one two three go
of soon
come on come on come on come on come on
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you take from this video it's kind
of impossible not to take something so
what did you take in this video that
you're going to immediately apply to
your life or to your business please
leave it down in the comments below I'm
super curious to find out I also want to
give a quick shadow to jamya expose
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word I guess the
eBook version of it I really really
really appreciate it and hope you are
enjoying it thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much love
I'll see you soon